so we have two vectors here vector a it
has a magnitude of three so the length
of this blue arrow is three and its
direction it forms a 30 degree angle
with the positive i guess you could say
the positive x axis didn't i haven't
drawn that here and vector b has a
magnitude of 2 the length of this arrow
is 2 and it forms 135 degree angle with
the positive x-axis and what i want to
think about in this video and maybe the
next one depends on how we do with time
is what is the magnitude and direction
of the sum of these two vectors what is
the magnitude and direction of the
vector a plus b and i encourage you to
pause this video and try to work this
through on your own before i work
through it
well to think about this i'm going to
decompose each of these vectors into
their horizontal and their vertical
components so for example vector a could
be viewed as the sum of this horizontal
pointing vector plus this vertical plus
this vertical pointing vector another
way of thinking about this horizontal
vector this right over here this is
going to be a scaled up version of the
unit vector i
and so this is going to be
this is going to be something times i
and this vector right over here is going
to be something times the unit vector in
the vertical direction the universe in
the vertical direction might look
something might look something like
might look something like
that or let's see if this is 3 then the
unit vector
actually would look something like that
so that's what the j unit vector looks
like and this is what the i unit vector
this is what the i unit vector would
look like
would look like so this is a scaled up
version of it so it's something times i
and this is something times j
and the same exact argument right over
here
right over here
this is going to be something times the
i unit vector its horizontal component
and its vertical component is going to
be something times the j unit vector so
what we really need to do is figure out
the magnitudes of these horizontal and
vertical components and then we know how
much to scale up i and how much to scale
up j
so let's think through this a little bit
so this one might jump out at you
immediately as this is a 30-60-90
triangle so this is a 30-60-90 triangle
then this side right over here is going
to be half the length of the hypotenuse
so this is going to be this is going to
be half of three so it's three over two
and this one right over here let me do
that same color
so this is going to be
three
that's not the same that's a different
color this is going to be 3
over 2 and then this length right over
here this is going to be square root of
3 times the shorter side so this is 3
times the square root of 3
over 2. i just took this and multiplied
by square root of 3. and once again that
just came out of 30 60
90 triangles now another way that you
could tackle this is to use your what
what you know about your trig functions
you can say okay i know this angle right
here is a 30 degree angle this is the
opposite side so you could say well the
opposite over three is going to be equal
to the sine of 30 degrees let me write
this down
so
ka
toa
sine
of 30 degrees is going to be equal to
i'll write
up is going to be equal to the opposite
side
over the length of the hypotenuse
over 3 or we could say that the opposite
side
or we could say that the opposite side
is equal to 3 times the sine of 30
degrees
3 times the sine
of 30 degrees and if you put this in
your calculator sine of 30 degrees is
one half and so you're going to get
three halves here similarly for this
side this side is adjacent to the 30
degree angle so you could say
cosine cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse you could say that cosine
of 30 degrees is equal to adjacent over
the hypotenuse or multiplying both sides
by three the adjacent is going to be
equal to
is going to be equal to 3 times the
cosine of 30 degrees
times the cosine of 30 degrees and the
cosine of 30 degrees if you type in your
calculator you're actually going to get
some type of a decimal but it's square
root of 3
over
2. so 3 squares to three over two and
you can you can verify this if you
if you like
so we see here sine of thirty
is indeed one half and cosine of thirty
well you get this kind of crazy decimal
but notice that is the same thing as
square root of 3
divided by
2 the exact same value right over here
but we were able to figure that out just
using what we know about 30 60 90
triangles
now this triangle you might say well
what's the angle what angles do we know
about it well this
angle right over here
this angle right over here is this is
supplementary to this 135 degree angle
so this is a 45 degree angle this is 90.
so this is 45 so this is a 45 45 90
degree triangle
now you could you could say that using
the trig identities and what we did
right over here that this is this length
is going to be the hypotenuse
times the cosine of 45 degrees
times the cosine of 45 degrees and you
could say that this length right over
here
is going to be the hypotenuse times the
sine of 45 degrees times the sine of 45
degrees using the exact same logic here
and as you get more practice with
finding the components you'll realize
okay you take the hypotenuse times the
cosine of the this angle you're going to
get or you're going to get the adjacent
side if you do the hypotenuse times the
sine of this angle you're going to get
the opposite side but we could use this
sine of 45 degrees once again if you put
in your calculator you get a crazy
decimal but we can figure that out we we
know 45 45 90 triangles sine of 45
degrees is square to 2
over 2 cosine of 45 degrees is also
square root of 2 over 2.
so i know my my writing is getting a
little bit messy and actually i should
have done all this in green square root
of 2
over 2. so what's the length of that
green vector well it's 2 times square
root of 2 over 2 that's going to be
square root of 2. what's the length of
this
orange vector it's 2 times square root
of 2 over 2 so it's going to be square
root of 2.
so now we know the magnitudes of the
component vectors the horizontal and
vertical components of each of these so
now we can we can write these out as the
sum of these horizontal and vertical
vectors
so vector a
vector a we can write as square root of
3 or 3 square roots of 3 over 2
times i that's this vector right over
here we've scaled up the i unit vector
by 3 square roots of 3 over 2
plus three halves
times j that's this this right over here
is
this vector right over here scaled up
version of the j unit vector and if you
add this orange vector to this green
vector you get vector a
similarly similarly
similarly
vector b
is equal to the length of the horizontal
component and we got to be very careful
its length is square root of 2 but it's
going in the leftward direction so we're
going to put a negative on it times i if
it was just squared i is doing something
like this square to 2 times i would look
like that so negative square root of 2
would point it to would point it to the
left so this is negative square root of
2 times i
and then we're going to have plus
plus square root of 2
square root of 2 times j
and so now that we've broken up them up
in their components we're ready to
figure out what at least broken up into
its components what a plus b is
so a plus b
a
plus b
is equal to well it's going to be the
sum of all of these things so let me
just write that down so it's going to be
that
so copy and paste
plus
this
plus this let me just copy
and paste it
and you're going to get that but of
course we can simplify this we can add
the i unit vectors to each other if i
have 3 times the square root of 3 over 2
i's and i have another negative square
root of two i's i can add that together
so this is going to be equal to
three times the square root of three
over two minus square root of two
times i
and then i can add this to this and i'm
going to get plus
3 halves plus square root of 2
times j
so it looks a little bit complicated but
we could type it into our calculator and
get approximations of each of these two
values and then we could and we
essentially have a at least a broken
down into its components representation
of a plus b
in the next video we're now going to
take this and figure out the actual
magnitude and direction of a plus b